back vice president kamala harris visits
the southern border for the first time
since being tapped to lead the biden
administration's response to the migrant
crisis
but some critics say she didn't do
enough white house correspondent peter
ducey is also on the ground in el paso
with some highlights from harris's visit
good evening peter
shannon good evening a few weeks ago
when the vice president went down to
central america
she warned migrants do not come
but today when she made her first trip
as vice president
to this side of the border she didn't
say that
i hope this does not sound trite or
corny
that we have the capacity to give people
hope closest the vice president got to
the border was
the inside of a dmv like port of entry
where people can walk across
and apply for asylum we have a line that
never stops the vice president didn't
spend much time at all talking about
illegal border crossers instead focusing
on the humanitarian
impact of recent surges this is this
issue cannot be reduced to a political
issue but that's what she did
at times it is here in el paso that the
previous administration's child
separation policy
was unveiled blaming the trump
administration for increased migration
we inherited a tough situation questions
about why the vp visited el paso
hundreds of miles away from the busiest
border crossings
have been answered i recommend it to the
vice president
that we visit el paso because it is one
of the busiest sectors on the border
busy is good according to the local
democratic congresswoman
welcome to el paso welcome to my
community to the new ellis island
the counterpoint comes from senator ted
cruz quote communities like el paso are
struggling because of the damage the
biden harris administration
has caused by opening the floodgates to
human smugglers and
drug cartels honestly this is a slap in
the face to the men and women that are
out there putting their lives on the
line
each and every day for at least 10 hours
a day
in areas which are a lot busier than
where she's going
she's getting the dog and pony show even
though the vice president has long
publicly claimed her focus is not on the
border
she says her trip to a border town was a
long time coming
how did you decide that right now was
the right time to make your first trip
to the border
well it's not my first trip i've been to
the border many times i'm the person in
charge of the response
so the important aspect of this visit
is leading this visit after
the work that we did in guatemala and
mexico because as i've long said i said
back in march i was going to come to the
border so this is not a new plan
the vice president did not mention
anything about those videos we've been
seeing lately of smugglers
freely ferrying people and drugs into
the country and she did not detail
what she thinks should happen to beef up
security at the most poorest parts of
the border instead
her focus was on trying to figure out
why it is that people leave home in the
first place instead of trying to figure
out
how to keep them home for now shannon
peter ducey traveling with vice
president thank you very much
and